it's a year since george floyd's death
unleashed a revolution in america but
sadly
it has not been a positive one calls
to defund the police led to budget cuts
not only in minneapolis but coast to
coast
from new york to los angeles police
morale has collapsed
criminals have been empowered with the
totally predictable and predicted
consequence a massive rise in violent
crime
in los angeles shootings up 73 percent
in new york
up 97 in minneapolis a 250 percent
increase
in gunshot victims who's hurt the most
black and latino americans in new york
last june
97 of shooting victims were minorities
in los angeles according to the police
chief nearly all
shooting victims in the 2020 crime surge
were in black and brown communities
listen to this report from minneapolis
the sound of gunfire
has become so familiar in one
predominantly black neighborhood
that residents have grown numb to it
now even the democrat politicians who a
year ago
pandered to defund the police activists
are coming to their senses and reversing
their reckless
dangerous undermining of the police
but there's another consequence of the
protests a year ago that could be even
more destructive
the protests helped advance a cause that
has been trying for
a hundred years to occupy the commanding
heights of american life
that cause is wokism which in the space
of just 12 months has become the new
religion
not just of the left but our corrupt and
decadent establishment
too you see it in the woke corporations
cravenly mouthing blm propaganda
mcdonald's changed their twitter handle
to amplifying black voices
companies including lockheed martin
indoctrinated their workforces
with racist training programs coca-cola
took
time out from their main mission of
destroying black people's health
to spread lies and misinformation about
voting reforms
you see it in the total capitulation of
the democratic party to the woke agenda
democrats
fighting to end policing abolish the
department of homeland security destroy
girls sports
manipulating our language to push
their divisive woke narrative they don't
even understand
what they're talking about anymore
wokism is not some
benign soft attempt to promote peace and
harmony
it's the exact opposite as we have
explained it is the product of a hundred
year long
effort to undermine and tear down the
values and ideals and freedoms
that this country was built on it
started in germany
1923 at the institute for social
research part of
frankfurt university's goethe institute
a group of marxist philosophers got
together to debate a central question
why did the working-class revolutions
predicted by marx and engels
not sweep the world their main
conclusion
the proletariat were held back by family
religion and culture these three things
they argued
were the building blocks of bourgeois
society
used by the elite to keep their masses
oppressed
so they invented a new theory which
explained all this
and explained how to dismantle those
building blocks it was called
critical theory many of these frankfurt
school philosophers as they became known
eventually made their way across the
atlantic to new york
where they took up residence at columbia
university's sociology department
critical theory became critical race
theory
it grew and spread throughout the 1970s
80s and 90s
to become the dominant on-campus
ideology that we see today
this is what these useful idiots in
corporate america
the democratic party and the media are
embracing
they have become the pathetic stooges of
our
number one domestic threat the real
enemy within
the tragedy of it all is that we do need
to do more
to address racial injustice in america
on median income the gap between white
and black americans
is over thirty thousand dollars
the average white household has nearly
18 times as much wealth as the average
black household
three-quarters of white americans own
their own home for black americans
it's less than half high school
graduation rates and nine percent higher
for white students and
perhaps the most destructive more black
people in jail
even though there are more than five
times as many white americans as black
americans
but what's the real explanation for all
this
the most pervasive cause of racial
injustice in america
is not racist white people it's the
policies of the democrats
that incentivize single parenthood lock
kids in schools that fail to give them a
decent education
policies that destroy community jobs so
what's the best
most positive most practical solution to
racial injustice
not the shallow virtue signaling of woke
ceos or
guilty white allies but conservative
ideas like stable families school choice
homeownership
and the kind of criminal justice reform
led by president trump
you want opportunity and social mobility
for black kids in america
make sure they're raised in a stable
loving home
if you're born in the bottom twenty
percent of the income scale
your chances of reaching the top twenty
percent are
four times higher if your parents stay
married marriage makes a massive
difference in keeping families stable
on average if parents are married three
quarters are still together by the time
their child is 12.
if they were just living together it's
only a quarter
you want to close the racial income and
wealth gap closed the racial education
gap
in california public schools totally
controlled by the teacher unions as we
saw in the pandemic
there's the equivalent of a four year
achievement gap
between black and white eighth grade
students in seattle the education gap is
so embarrassingly wide
they've stopped reporting the data
whereas
students from la charter schools are far
more likely to be eligible for state
universities
than their peers in union-run schools
and seattle charter school students
gained the equivalent of between 30
and nearly 60 more days of learning if
black lives really mattered to the
democrats
they'd back these kinds of reforms but
they don't
they block them gavin newsom so pleased
with himself and his sanctimonious blm
virtue signaling
is trying to shut down charter schools
the very schools that help black kids
the most
we need to help black people in america
climb the ladder of opportunity
and the first step is to fix the wrongs
broken
by disastrous democrat policy but it's
not just about policy
it's about our culture too if black
lives
really mattered to the woke ceos and the
media and the activists
they'd use their platforms to promote a
culture
of achievement and success researchers
have established with data
what the pathway out of poverty is it's
called the success
sequence get at least a high school
diploma get a job
get married before having children only
three percent of millennials who
followed this success sequence
were in poverty by the time they reached
adulthood we can teach this
promote this put money behind the
message finish high school get a job get
married
that's what we need in this country not
the nihilistic divisive
anti-american poison of wokism
which paints every black person as a
victim and every white person
an oppressor and at the heart of it all
we need to rebuild the american family
the very thing
that woke ism is aiming to destroy
so as we mark the anniversary of this
social upheaval
let's say clearly that conservatives
should lead this fight
the fight against woke-ism and the fight
for
equal opportunity for every american
regardless
of race hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else